جلست زميلي في قناة CNN أليكس توماس
مع نجمة lpj ليديا كو
بعد فوزها في بطولة BMW
للسيدات في كوريا الجنوبية ، وتحدثت
عن كونها واحدة من النجوم في
جولة Tiger Woods PGA
2K 23 التي طال انتظارها.
[موسيقى]
نعم  رائع جدًا عندما تم الاقتراب مني
للحصول على فرصة المشاركة فيها ، كنت
مثل ما أنا وأه ، نعم رائع
جدًا وأعتقد أنها طريقة رائعة
للأشخاص الذين ربما لا يلعبون
الجولف بالضرورة أو يعرفون لعبة السيدات
مثلهم  لمعرفة اللاعبين المختلفين
الموجودين هناك وخاصة بعض
لاعبي LPGA الآخرين ، ونأمل أن
يجذب انتباههم ويرغب
في الخروج ومشاهدتنا نلعب على الهواء مباشرة وكذلك
أجنبيًا ما
مدى دقة
مقارنة Lydia Co الرقمية في رأيك بـ  شركة Lydia الحقيقية
هناك
[موسيقى]
يجب أن أعمل بجهد أكبر للحصول على تلك
الأكتاف اللطيفة وكذلك تلك
العجول اللطيفة المظهر ولكن نعم الجزء السفلي من
الجسم أشعر أنه أصبح قويًا جدًا
ولكن الجزء العلوي من الجسم هو أحد الجوانب التي أعمل بها
مع مدربي في الواقع ،
وأنني في اللعبة أبدو رائعًا ، لذا كنت
مثل هذا هدفي ،
إنه مثير للاهتمام أليس هو مقدار المزيد من
التكنولوجيا المستخدمة في أعلى مستوى
من لعبة الجولف التي يُفترض أنها مثل لاعبين آخرين
لديك بيانات متأرجحة تُدخل فيها  ما
كنت تعمل عليه خلال
روتينك التدريبي ، أستخدم شاشة الإطلاق التي
تتحقق فقط من معرفتك بتدوير نادي SB الخاص بي ،
فقط تأكد من أنني كنت على دراية
بالاتصال ولكني أحاول ألا أشعر بالجنون مع
مثل الأرقام وكل شيء فقط  حاول أن
تبقيه بسيطًا جدًا ،
لكنني أعتقد بالتأكيد بالنسبة لأولئك الذين يرغبون حقًا في
استخدامه ، إنه جانب رائع
وبالتأكيد شيء مفيد للغاية
ولكن عليك استخدامه إلى
المدى المناسب للاعب المناسب لأنه لمجرد
أن شخصًا ما لديه هذا
هذا وقد لا يكون هذا هو الشيء الصحيح بالنسبة
لك
لاعبي الغولف الأجانب على هذا الكوكب في الأشهر الأخيرة ، حيث
لعبت تسعة أحداث بما في ذلك حدثان رئيسيان
وانتهت فقط خارج المراكز الخمسة الأولى
في ثلاث مناسبات
أخبرنا المزيد عن  كم كان من دواعي سروري
أن أرى هذا التناسق يكافأ
بفوز في بطولة
رفيعة المستوى مثل بطولة BMW للسيدات
التي دخلت مسيرتي في عطلة نهاية الأسبوع ، أردت فقط
أن ألعب لبعض الوقت بينما كان الكثير من
أفراد عائلتي يتواجدون
هناك لذلك أنا  أردت أن أظهر بعض الجولف الجيد
لأنه مرت بضع سنوات
منذ أن لعبت أمامهم آخر مرة
وكانت بالتأكيد لا
تنسى وعاطفية كما أعتقد